what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so I've been thinking recently
about Loki and Avengers four and I have
been thinking that Loki's alive and I
think I know what Loki's doing so all
this really comes down to a theory that
was confirmed by the heads of the MCU
that Loki was under the control of the
mind stuff right like that's that was
the theory they've been circulating
around for a long time because people
had been looking at the transition of
Loki nothing in a Marvel Cinematic
Universe ever really happens without an
intention when it comes to like
character development
I mean there are potholes there's
potholes in every movie see revery movie
franchise ever I mean like Harry Potter
is a really good example hey guys we
have a time Turner let's just go back in
time and stop Voldemort from like when
he rose to power let's just kill him you
know and then like you know we won't
have to worry about it or anything let's
just like he'll owe money Tom Riddle
well now that makes too much sense
because then you know we can't write
seven bucks so I mean there's plotholes
million all kinds of different stuff but
nonetheless when it comes to Loki really
liked the idea that he'd been under the
control of mind stone since Avengers
fits well and it actually fits into this
theory and the reason why is because
when this theory was confirmed what it
did is it said okay so like Loki
basically pops up in Avengers and
becomes a bad guy like we'd seen him
before Avengers right like we see him in
Thor but like when he was in the the
Thor film he wasn't like a straight-up
villain like he was in in the the movie
Avengers I mean he was kind of a bad guy
but he was a bad guy more so you know
insofar as like hey you know I'm trying
to like seize control the throne or
whatever but when you get to Avengers
he's just like everyone needs to die
like I hate everybody and everything
he's like every fifteen-year-old emo kid
ever right he's like everybody needs to
die and like I hate everything and you
know I'm so misunderstood by the world
all that kind of stuff and so you look
at that and then you look at like his
subsequent appearances and he becomes
less and less villainous as his
subsequent appearances go on now the
idea behind this initially was that well
it's just the character development of
Loki but when the fan Theory came out
and while wil confirmed it that Loki was
controlled by the mind stone and it's
like okay that makes sense so like in
Avengers he was controlled by the mind
stone and just fueled his hatred for his
brother in for earth and that's why he
was just such a dick you know so I was
like okay that makes sense so then once
it becomes his real self
he becomes a lot more toned down and he
becomes really more like an antihero if
not like a straight-up hero is like the
the movies begin to progress the movies
begin to go on but here's the funny
thing about this
so with that having been said and Marvel
Comics while Doctor Strange is the
sorcerer supreme rila he's the guy that
they're supposed to know the most about
magic although that kind of changes
based on the story the person that I
would say knows the most about
dimensions and like the various little
pocket
realities and so on and so forth that
are out there outside Oh dr. strange is
loki and the reason why is because dr.
strange and loki are the two most
traveled beings out there when it comes
to sorcery right like you've got the
scarlet witch who uses her powers of
sorcery but she doesn't really jump from
one dimension to the next brother voodoo
did kind of a little bit but not on the
same level as like dr. strange i said
like when it comes to dr. strange and
loki their journeys into like alternate
realities and to like other dimensions
and things like that is hitherto
unrivaled
and so we could easily take that and
transition it over to like loki as a
character because here's the issue all
we really know about loki is that like
he's the adopted son of Odin of course
he was he's basically like a frost giant
more or less and that he was kind of a
dick when he was younger and a little
bit of a mischief-maker but we don't
really know like everything loki was
doing between the time that he was like
a little kid and the time that he grew
up to be an adult and even then like
during the time when he was in adulthood
which however many thousands of years
that went on for we don't really know
exactly what all was going on and it
could just be that because of the fact
that thor was like the prize son of Odin
and that Odin was kind of like Loki do
your thing as long as you don't create
problems that traveling outside of
Asgard and going to like other
dimensions right going like the other
realms like Jotunheim and all that kind
of stuff and to explain that for a
second if those are guys who don't know
cuz a lot of people find this really
really confusing so in Marvel Comics
what you have is you have what are
called pocket dimensions right I want to
talk about this for a second it kind of
comes out of nowhere but bear with me
you have what are called pocket
dimensions right like pocket dimensions
are basically like smaller universes
right so you have like the Marvel
Cinematic Universe in its entirety and
then inside of that universe you have a
smaller universe which is called Asgard
and then you have another smaller
universe which is called like like
Jotunheim and then you have like another
smaller universe called Hell which is
the realm of Hell and so on and so forth
they are individual realities so the
only way to really access those is to
literally use the Bifrost it's it's
exactly what it sounds like it's a
bridge that literally bridges from one
universe to the next and so all the
Bifrost really does is essentially open
a wormhole from like one universe to
another universe and that's how they
travel from realm to realm
you can't leave Earth in in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe you can't leave Earth
travel far enough and reach Asgard you
have to kind of break through a
dimensional barrier travel into the
pocket universe of Asgard and then
that's when you'll find the actual
kingdom of Asgard the same thing with
like yo tin hime and all that kind of
good stuff so that's why you never see
the guardians of the galaxy like travel
like say okay guys we're going on a
mission and then just hit like hyper
speed and then travel to Jotunheim it
doesn't really work that way nonetheless
that's that's kind of how that little
that little tidbit remains those guys
who were who are curious about that but
unless when it comes to Loki here's
here's what I think
been going on so in reality if you look
at Loki for what he is Loki is
exceedingly smart right he's not like a
genie so I like Reed Richards
intelligent but he's very very smart in
terms of like mysticism and and just
having been alive for like a really long
time like we just down and he says okay
so like basically I was under the
control of the mind stone by Thanos
right like so we're long the law and he
had to have realized that like he had to
have come to grips with that fact and
understood that's what was going on and
then in turn lucky we have to sit under
realize okay any artifact out there in
the universe is powerful enough to
basically like take over the mind of
gods has to be exceedingly powerful not
from there you can assume Loki went on
kind of a journey of sorts and I okay
what are the Infinity stones what can
they do so on and so forth you know what
are they capable of because I have a
hard time believing Loki would have gone
into the events of like infinity war
having no idea what the Infinity
Gauntlet was or what it was capable of
or anything like that like Odin knew
what the Infinity stones were but he
knew how powerful they were and he knew
that if they were brought together that
they would basically create like an
unstoppable force you know in terms of
the person who's wielding it and so Loki
in of himself could have just gone to
investigate that now having said that if
floki came to that realization then you
would have to sit down and say okay then
we can't stop them on our own like
there's no conceivable way to do that
earth superheroes cannot stop Thanos
it's impossible because he's just that
strong my even their sorcerer supreme
Doctor Strange which the last indication
that there's no indication that Loki
really knows about Doctor Strange really
she has any information about how
powerful Doctor Strange is by the time
we get to the events of infinity war
because Loki was presumably dead by then
and so even if that was the case though
Loki would have to look back and say
okay but even Doctor Strange wouldn't be
powerful enough to stop Thanos with the
Infinity Gauntlet Loki would go on this
mission to say we need to find those who
aren't anyone makes sense at Loki would
in turn track down the cosmic entities
and here's the reason why is because in
Marvel Comics it was Adam warlock who
pulled that off right like it was Adam
warlock who basically said okay so like
we're gonna have two battles here one
battle is basically gonna be a sham and
the other battle is gonna be the actual
war so like when when the Infinity
Gauntlet event popped off they don't got
the Infinity stones Adam warlock was
woken up and then he him him and
Gomorrah and pip the troll once you go
gather what was left of the earth
superheroes what Adam warlock didn't
tell them is that they were basically
gonna be cannon fodder
it's like Cyclops Wolverine name with a
submariner Nova like like
what does it Eric Masterson Thor they
were all basically be cannon fodder
there's nothing they could do to stop
the knows but the idea behind that was
to at the very least like test Stannis
and see what he could do and then from
there grabbed the cosmic entities and
bring them in and then use the cosmic
entities as a way to try to defeat
Thanos I mean all of it really
came down on the silver surfer right
like the idea was to throw all those
guys in there all the earthbound heroes
in there and say all of you fight Thanos
you're all gonna be a distraction in a
moment of hubris Stannis is gonna let
his guard down Silver Surfer is gonna
race off he's gonna try to grab the
gauntlet and then of course Silver
Surfer failed so then Adam warlock
called in the called in the the cosmic
entities none of which stood a chance
they were all basically defeated they
fell before the power of the gauntlet
now how the cosmic entities will fare
against Thanos in the MCU is anybody's
guess because a lot of things are deep
powered like a lot of things are not
really be powered they're very very
they're far less powerful in the movies
than they are in the comics now a lot of
that's done just for the sake of
believability if we actually had Thanos
with the Infinity Gauntlet from Marvel
Comics in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
in the totality of its power doing all
the things he did in the Infinity
Gauntlet comic then people would just be
like well this is hopeless like no one's
gonna be able to stop him although I
think it would be cooler I think it
would be cool if the movie ended the
same way the comic did and that Thanos
basically falls prey to his own
arrogance but nonetheless it is cool in
this this little tidbit because with
with Loki being out there like let's
assume for example that he did faked his
own death that he cast a giant illusion
because at the time danos did not have
the reality stone sothe anos would not
be able to differentiate between the
illusion Loki cast and reality itself
and if Loki is knowledgeable about the
Infinity stones and Loki knows that
Thanos doesn't have the reality stone
then he could cast a delusion of his own
death makes Thanos believe he died and
then in turn like disappear just like
like vanish into the sunset and go track
down the cosmic entities and in tracking
down the cosmic entities we know they're
the ones who created the Infinity stones
right like we know that from guardians
of the galaxy we know that from the
guardians galaxy handbook that was
released alongside the blu-ray I think
it was like Marvel's release information
telling us where the Infinity stones
came from so like we know that cosmic
entities were the ones who made them so
the cosmic entities were the ones who
made them then the cosmic entities are
the ones who could D power them so
literally Loki goes and grabs the cosmic
entities brings them back probably at
the end or something like that the
cosmic entities are just like done and
it would basically be the Marvel
Cinematic Universe equivalent of like
infinity War part 1 right like from that
from the comics when like Adam warlock
had the affinity gauntlet started going
crazy and you know thought he could show
off to the Living Tribunal and let me
tributyl just shut down the Infinity
Gauntlet
it was just like your your powers
nullified now that's it the Infinity
Gauntlet will not work until this trial
is done it was a crazy Display of power
even Adam warlock who's just kinda like
what but again like Loki could take the
place of Adam because with everything
that's gone on with James Gunn as far as
we're aware like Adam warlock is done
and gone now like he's never gonna get
never gonna appear in the MCU unless
somebody else decide to bring him back
or at least they're never there
James Gunn script for guardians 3 as far
as I'm aware I think it's kind of up in
the air I think we're hearing news from
both sides like yes they're gonna use it
no they're not I'll think it's really
been confirmed I'm not a hard person
sure I don't really looked into that but
unless it makes sense that look you
would pull that off if you're if you're
dr. strange and you're sitting down
you're saying okay here's all the pieces
on the board like Loki is the one thing
that Dan owes is not expecting right
like it's the one thing Fanus doesn't
count on because as far as Stannis is
concerned
Loki's dead and so it would it would
come out of nowhere if suddenly Loki
reappeared with the cosmic entities
because he would throw Thanos Thanos off
guard because he wouldn't see it coming
because it's a one thing he didn't
expect and that of course is assuming
that US doesn't understand the origin of
the Infinity stones which there's reason
to believe he doesn't know where they
came from because he's never offered an
explanation on where they came from all
he knows is that they exist and he
tracked him down and captured him but if
he doesn't know the full story behind
them and Loki does the nest Loki's trump
card and that's the plan that dr.
strange was counting on it's the idea
the dog strains like okay so with
everything that's happened so far
everything transpiring the way that it
does Loki has to go round up the cosmic
entities and bring them in and that's
gonna be like literally it's gonna bring
it into everything but I don't know I
mean at this point again like it's a
crapshoot
I mean Marvel is so hush-hush about like
what's going on with like with Avengers
for like all the trailers has just said
like this is a movie that's happening
and it comes out in April see you then
that's basically it we have like no real
spoilers for what's going on which is
really really cool to see that they're
playing so playing it so close to the
best okay like I hate having trailers
you just blow everything but nonetheless
you know you guys think down in the
comments section I'm curious what your
theory is if you guys are new here to
come this explain make sure you guys
have the sub button to become part of
the rob4 if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and yeah I
will catch you all later peace
you